I'm in favor of legislating the first
table of the law.
>> If you legislate any of the four
commandments on the first table, it will
lead to persecution.
>> Would you use your second amendment
rights for blue laws? Second amendment
has to do with weapons.
>> It is the business of the gospel to
convict hearts, not to force hands.
>> During the apartate era, we had very
stringent blue laws. We had a Christian
government.
>> Christian nationalist.
>> A Christian nationalist government. The
persecution that came from that was
quite harsh.
>> Our concern is is that long-term our
people are going to be facing
imprisonment as they did back in 1888.
>> And if that were to happen, that would
be bad, but it would be way better than
what you're going through now.
>> How so? If I'm enforcing something that
impedes your free right, that's not the
way of Christ.
>> We're not here saying, "No, we don't
want anything to be moral." When you
have blue laws, that's something that
Anglicans, congregationalists,
Presbyterians, Baptists can all agree
on. The 7th Day Adventists wouldn't.
But, you know, things are tough all
over.
>> The kingdom of God is something that
happens within and cannot be enforced
from without. It is that final decision
will determine who is part of the
kingdom of God and who is not.
>> Hello, welcome back to Heritage and Hope
Ministries. And before we get started,
I'd like to introduce everyone that's
joining the conversation today. Uh for
the first time on the show, we're joined
by Pastor Douglas Wilson, who many of
you may recognize from his recent viral
CNN interview or from podcast and
discussions with figures like Tucker
Carlson and Steven Wolf. He's the senior
pastor of Christ Church in Moscow,
Idaho. He is an author, educator, and
theologian who has been a leading voice
in the Christian nationalist movement.
Often speaking and writing on issues of
theology, culture, and society from a
reformed evangelical perspective. We're
delighted once again to have Dr. Walter
Vith and Martin Smith with us from South
Africa. Dr. Vith is a respected
evangelist and author widely known for
his presentations on creation science
and end time prophecy. Martin Smith has
long partnered with him as co-host and
co-director. And together they've
reached a global audience through their
Clash of Minds YouTube channel and the
popular series What's Up Prof, where
they examine current events through a
biblical and prophetic perspective. And
of course, we're your hosts, James and
myself, representing Heritage and Hope
Ministries. Our passion is uncovering
and affirming Protestant history through
historic books and documents while
connecting it with scripture, prophecy,
and current events to help prepare God's
people for the final days ahead. So, as
always, you will find links for each
guest and their ministry in the
description below. So, thank you so much
for joining us. James, let's uh let's
bow our heads and have a quick word of
prayer just to get started and then
let's uh kind of launch into it. Our
dear father in heaven, thank you for
your many wonderful blessings. Thank you
that we could join together for this
conversation. I pray that you would
please be with us here. Help your truth
to shine through and for us to see the
power and the love that Jesus had at the
cross for us for dying humanity. And I
pray these things in Jesus name. Amen.
All right, James, Pastor Wilson, thank
you so much for joining us today. Uh you
know, over the past few years, it's been
very interesting. Uh we've we've had an
opportunity to kind of monitor the rise
of Christian nationalism, the push for
church state unification, and we've
really enjoyed some exciting discussions
with Lennox, California there from New
St. Andrews. And uh we've been observing
some of the statements made from Pastor
Jared Longshore, Timone Klene, Joel
Webbon, Steven Wolf, SAB Amari, Dr. Chad
Pecnold and there's a whole long list of
other influencers out there who are
advocating for certain changes to
address some of the concerns that I
think a lot of Christians are
recognizing within society today. Uh and
advocating some solutions of course
whether or not those solutions are the
right way to go. We we would like to
review that a little bit. But one thing
I wanted to clarify when we spoke with
Lennox uh he stated at one point that he
believed in separation of church and
state and when we watched the Naton
interview with Timone Klene who has been
uh featured on some of the discussions
with Dr. Longore uh he stated there the
video headline was the case for
renouncing separation of church and
state. So I wanted to clarify what the
position was there because it to me it
sounded like maybe New St. Andrews was
uh advocating on the one hand for very
clearly renouncing separation of church
and state but Lennox's position was uh
that he believed for separation of
church and state. We we wanted to begin
before we go further just clarifying
what your position was on separation of
church and state.
>> Um yes there are two two layers here.
One is that the separation of church and
state has to do with the distinction of
governments. So you've got the
government of the church and the
government of the civil authority. And I
believe in the separation of church and
state. The problem is that in modern
discourse uh that phrase separation of
church and state is made synonymous with
separation of God and state, the
separation of morality and state, the
separation of Christianity and state,
which I don't believe is possible,
right? Um so basically um a good example
of this was in the American founding
there were numerous uh states that had a
formal relationship with the Christian
denomination. Um at least four of them
had uh well three uh had a an
established faith an established
denomination at the state level that was
prohibited at the federal level. the
Congress shall make no law concerning
the establishment of religion. And that
was because that was state business, not
because it was um rejected. Right? So
now I happen to believe that that u an
established state religion at the state
level is not a good not a good idea not
a good arrangement but it's not an
unconstitutional
arrangement because at at the at the
time of the founding at least nine of
the 13 states had some sort of formal
relationship with a Christian
denomination or other South Carolina uh
simply said that the Protestant
evangelical ical religion is the
official religion of the state of South
Carolina without establishing a
particular denomination. So I'm in favor
of uh a formal recognition of the
Protestant faith as the as the faith of
the state and the people. But I don't
think tax money ought to go to a
particular denomination. So yes to
separation of church and state, but I do
believe that there needs to be a working
relationship between the state and the
um uh and the church.
>> Well, you know, uh it's interesting you
mentioned Protestant. One of the
concerns, you know, from our perspective
is when we look at James Madison, his
statement to Jasper Adams was that in
the papal system, government and
religion are in a manner consolidated
and that it is found to be the worst of
governments. He also went on to state
that the number, industry and morality
of the priesthood have been manifestally
increased by the total separation of
church from the state. So I guess this
builds into our next question is if you
if you believe in separation of church
and state and you are advocating for
blue laws in particular, doesn't that
establish at least one religion uh as
having power or authority with the state
over others on different days?
Yeah, I I believe that a civil order
should be explicitly Christian,
right? And even uh even Rhode Island at
the founding had blue laws, right? And
Rhode Island would be the most um down
the road of keeping everything distinct
because of uh Roger Williams convictions
on that on that matter. Um, so basically
I don't think it's possible for a civil
order to be neutral when it comes to
Islam, Hinduism, secularism, atheism,
and Christianity.
Basically, you've got to choose who who
you're going to serve. And and if you
have a a Christian consensus, a
Christian people, I think that that
should be reflected in common sense laws
that that this general consensus
supports. So when you have a blue when
you have blue laws um like you stores
have to be closed on Sunday those those
sorts of laws uh that's something that
Anglicans congregationalists
Presbyterians Baptists can all agree on.
The 7th day Adventists wouldn't but you
know things are tough all over. All
right. Now, that is exactly where we
come in because uh we actually also like
you believe in the separation of church
and state.
But the issue is we are also evangelical
as it were. We are Protestants. We come
from a Protestant, deep Protestant
background. We are Christ centered. We
believe in righteousness by faith. We
believe in obedience to God. We believe
that if you love God, you will keep his
commandments. All of these issues, we
are in accordance with exactly what
you've been saying. I listened to your
talk to CNN and there are so many points
of contact where uh when you look at
society today we can say you know we can
really we can really agree that society
is in a mess
and that there are many issues like this
but if we are a a Christian organization
and a Christian nation what if there are
differences in terms of worshiping God
within Christianity ity and the big
issue of course will be the issue of the
Sabbath day. So if there are blue laws
and if blue laws are propagated and then
we'll have a juosition between the
Sunday and the Sabbath
and the Christian denominations will say
but that is keeping a Jewish tradition
but we will argue that it comes from
Genesis long before there was a Jew. So
it seems you stated on CNN that when two
walk together they should be agreed or
how can they walk together and you you
stated that in particular with relation
to Islam. But what if Christians walk
together and there is a divide on which
day to worship and if that day should be
legislated what would be the
consequence?
Okay. So, um, what I would do, one of
the things you have to budget for is
what is the demographic composition of
the Christians in this Christian nation
that you're building? If the Seventh Day
Adventists are uh a a an overwhelming
minority, then what's going to happen?
If the majority is thinking the way I'm
thinking which is in terms of mere
Christendom which is very different than
detailed um detailed doctrinal getting
into details of doctrine what you would
have is the stores would all close on
Sunday and Adventists would be allowed
to close their their stores on Saturday.
There'd be no restriction of uh of them.
And then if you had adventists uh uh who
worked for let's say uh first day
sabotarians you had adventists who were
employees you would have a struct the
structure of the laws in such a way as
to be friendly to the adventists who
wanted to take uh Saturday off and have
you know you ba basically there's no re
there's no reason to be coercing anybody
but the way it would go
most of the stores would follows if most
of the Christians are first day are are
first day observers. Um so ba basically
a mere Christendom would have a high
degree of religious toleration for
denominational differences
>> under those circumst
>> what you wouldn't have what you wouldn't
have is 247 frenetic you know spend
spend spend bye bye bye all the time you
uh everything would shut down
>> we would have no problem I think with
with a situation like that at all but if
one one side becomes prescriptive over
the other and uh let's say labor laws
make it almost impossible to have two
days because the world is basically
asking for a synchronized day of rest.
If you take the argument of the European
bishops and the Sunday uh propagating
organizations in Europe, their argument
is for the sake of the family, we need
to have a synchronized day of rest
because what's the good if one of the
parents is off on the Sunday and the
other one works on a Sunday or off on a
Wednesday or a Thursday or a Saturday
and if the labor laws are such that that
a synchronized day eventually leads to
only the Sunday being available for that
synchronization for the sake of the
family. What if the laws move in that
direction? Then you start legislating
the first table of the decalogue.
>> Yeah. I'm I'm in favor of legislating
the first table of the law. Right. But I
I'm also in favor of doing it with the
accumulated wisdom that we've gathered
in the course of the first
Christristendom. So at the American at
the American founding, this is not a new
problem. Uh there were carveouts made
for Seventh Day Baptist, Seventh Day
Advent. Uh well, the Adventists weren't
there yet, but for Jews, for people who
observed a different day of rest, uh
there were uh legal carveouts, which I
would hardily support. basically uh part
of the part of the establishment of a
Christian uh ethos is respect for
liberty of conscience. So if if someone
differs from you and it's not disturbing
the peace then you you accommodate them
as far as it's possible to accommodate
them. Now, if I can imagine a a country
where 99.9%
of the population uh is observing the
first day and the guy who's got
convictions that it's that it's
Wednesday, he's going to he's going to
have a tough time of it, right? Um and
what he needs to do to resolve it is um
persuade people. Uh but in the meantime,
we shouldn't be mean to him. We
shouldn't persecute him. But I I do
think there's a great value in a society
being on the same clock.
>> Pastor Wilson, uh it's interesting you
mention that because if we go back to
early American history, in the colonies
of Virginia, the third penalty for
Sunday violations was the death penalty.
And in the Maryland Toleration Act, the
third penalty was a public whipping or
beating. And our concern is if we go
back to 1888 in a time period where
there was a similar push, similar logic,
similar values, similar appeals to the
founding of our country, uh there were
individuals who established and
advocated for laws that did not allow an
exemption for an Adventist who felt uh
morally in inclined under the
commandment of God to work on six days
out of the week. In other words, working
also on the first day of the week. here
in around our area near Chattanooga,
Tennessee, there were actually numbers
of our people who were arrested and put
in jail. And our concern is when we hear
Jared Longshore talking about we want to
be careful or with Timone Klein actually
which day we establish, it's very clear
that there's a law or there's a desire
there to advocate for Sunday
establishment. And my concern is that
there are many Christian nationalists
today who do not view that there should
be any exemption clause. And back in
1888, one of ours who argued before
United States Labor Committee actually
had concerned that a toleration clause
was all an exemption clause would amount
to being. is just another step towards
ultimately removing that because as
you're probably aware there's a
constitutional appeal uh specifically to
article 1 section 7 clause 2 where it
talks about Sunday uh Saturday is not
mentioned Sunday is mentioned there and
so I think the concern is that at some
point down the road any exemption clause
is going to be incrementally phased out
and I think you know we've actually
watched the interview with yourself and
Stephen Wolf where you spoke and asked
him about whether or not this should be
incrementally implemented or whether or
not it should be all at once. The
>> the old Baptist the old Baptist would
certainly be in favor of a of a hey no
ordinary commerce on a Sunday,
>> right? How much of an incrementalist are
you? Uh do you does your ideal political
leader get into power and then shoot the
moon? Um Sabbath legislation uh the
whole deal or do you wait in from the
shallow end? Yeah, you always have an
ideal. You have uh the perfect the
perfect regime, but you have to assess
the situation. You have to understand
the characteristics and nature of the
people think. So, you mentioned 55%. I I
don't think that you even have to have
55% of support or or you know, a
majority. I mean, I guess I'm an elitist
in that sense, but in the way there's a
lot of people who will just kind of
shift with the imagination set by the
people, the the ruling class.
>> And so, and so you don't need you don't
actually don't need like a majority
support of the population. You just need
a strong willed minority and then th
that ruling class can shape the
imagination of the majority which I
think Trump is doing now because for
decades we've had a very kind of weak
right when it comes to imposing your
will upon the executive branch and now
he's actually revealing to the country
that oh wait there is this executive who
who's vested with the executive power
who can exercise power within his
branch. We've seen those discussions
with Steven Wolf where it's going that
direction and our concern is is that
long-term down the road our people are
going to be facing imprisonment in the
future as they did back in 1888.
>> So, um, and if that were to happen, that
would be bad, right? But if that bad
thing happened, it would be way better
than what you're going through now.
>> How so?
Um we we just finished slaughtering 60
million babies.
All right. In other words, what people
do is when we when you uh postulate a
Christendom, it it is um reasonable and
understandable why we would project what
might go wrong if we if we establish my
idea of mere Christendom. Are there
going to be Christian nationalists who
want to be less tolerant than I want to
be of differences between Christians?
Yes, I'm sure I'm sure that's going to
happen. And that's why we have to have a
vigorous debate. But the the thing that
we have going on now, clown world going
on now, where they're mutilating
children, where uh uh children are being
dismembered, their parts are being sold
off. Um, you have uh Adventists and
first day sabotarians and Christians of
all stripes not being given the
toleration of their conscience on all
kinds of basic things. People losing
their jobs because they won't bake the
cake or they you know all of this stuff.
We live in a uh what I call a total
tolerant society um where they they're
imposing all sorts of things. So we are
in the we are in the bad part of the
movie now with regard to the secular
experiment. Now if we reject secularism
I'm I'm fond of saying if you enroll in
a math class the first thing you're
going to have is math problems right um
if we adopt a Christian nationalist
approach if we establish Christendom
again christryendom 2.0
I want us to learn the lessons from
Christendom 1.0. I don't want another
Spanish Inquisition. I don't, you know,
I don't want that stuff. I don't want a
Baptist minister flogged uh as one was
flogged in Virginia. U I I don't want
that. I want Christendom 2.0 to work
those bugs out. Right. But what's the
alternative? The alternative is where we
are now where people are arguing for
seriously arguing for transhumanism
uh genetic engineering splicing human
beings with uh animals that we're we're
in the middle of a brave new world. And
I don't believe I don't believe that we
should be spooked by what some
Christians did 300 years ago and what
some Christians are talking about. Hey,
wouldn't it be nice, you know, if we
were to go back to that? I'm opposed to
that, but that's not the big danger
right now. That's not That's really not
the big danger. So, it's sort of like
we're all in the fire. I view view it
like this. We're all in the fire and I'm
suggesting that we get back in the
frying pan and someone says, "Hey, we
can't get back in the frying pan because
that might lead to us falling in the
fire." Say, "We're in the fire now." To
your point,
>> I agree with you in the sense that
Christianity has a certain moral
standard.
uh which is not necessarily part of the
of the secular world. And the debate as
you say about all those children that
are being slaughtered or aborted is a
debate on where does life begin? Does it
begin with conception? Does it begin
with birth? We know all of those
arguments and when life starts, at what
term, and all of these things. We
believe like you that we are made in the
image of God and that the state has the
right to legislate the second table.
Thou shalt not kill. So as far as all of
those laws go are concerned with a
Christian influence on the state in
order to see that right occurs on that
issue. But when it comes to the first
table we have a problem. For example,
the first Sunday laws by Constantine,
they were rest days for Sunday. But then
the Roman Catholic Church came at the
council of Litia and stated, "No,
Christians may not Judaize. They may not
keep the Sabbath day, the seventh day."
And then persecution started and the
Valdenzas were persecuted. those that
kept the Sabbath and the albagenzas and
down through the line in Ethiopia, the
Celtic church. There was a tremendous
persecution on that issue. Then
Protestantism
brought a measure of rest and the
various canton then also started
legislating Christian principles and
there was again an issue that if you
didn't agree with the mainline churches
there was tremendous persecution whether
it was the Anabaptists or whether it was
even the Baptist or even the Methodists
how they treated them in the beginning
and they came to the United States and
it was decided that this would not take
place anymore. So once you start
legislating that first table which is
between you and God that is where we see
the problem and the issues that you
raised are are logical. I mean those are
issues of morality where Christian
morality must have a tremendous
influence on the society in which they
live. We all agree with that. Our
problem is the first table, your
relationship between God and uh that is
clearly defined. You shall have no other
gods beside me. And I remember in your
interview with CNN, you actually stated
that uh Islam in their countries are
entitled to do what they like, but you
would still like to evangelize them
because you believe that the God who is
the God of this universe is the God of
the Bible. That is the first
commandment. The second commandment has
to do with idolatry. you're going to
have a hard time uh fixing that since
Rome removed that commandment and uh
seems to be open to that kind of
worship.
And then you come down to blasphemy
laws. I mean, it's ridiculous what's
happening in the world concerning those
laws. And then the Sabbath. The Sabbath
remains the pivotal issue because it
determines who you acknowledge as your
creator and as your redeemer.
And this is where the divide is going to
come. And the Catholic law also
ensconced in its catechism
is that Christians must ensure that
Sunday becomes the day of rest. And the
present pope has aligned himself with uh
the previous Leo who brought about the
rum Novarum document where he clearly
states that the state must guarantee
that Sunday becomes the official day of
rest and this is our big our big problem
in this situation.
So a a couple of things. The first is I
don't I don't see how you can uh
legislate in terms of the second table
of the law without reference to the
first table because respect for human
life has to be respect for human life
because humans are made in the image of
God. And if and so this goes back to the
first commandment um I am the Lord your
God. And so if I if you allow for uh if
you don't enforce the first table of the
law, if you if you don't have your laws
based on the first table, you've got no
reason for defending the second table.
You have no reason to not allow Muslim
uh government officials, Hindu
government officials, atheist government
officials. And but once you have atheist
government officials or Muslim
government officials, you don't have the
same respect for human life grounded on
the on the same principle. So in order
to have a Christian respect for life in
the second table, you have to have some
acknowledgement of the first table. Now
I want to I want to argue uh that the
taking the the the sweep of redemptive
history in scripture and also
postappostolic
uh Christian history there's certain
things we should have learned in the
first christristendom and one of them is
that Christians ought not to be
persecuting Christians right that's
that's one of the that's one of the
lessons but it's not persecution for us
to decide that all of us are going to
close our stores on Sunday and we're not
going to and we're not going to hassle
the guys who want to close their stores
on Saturday.
I think that that is a reasonable way to
go. And so and and that means that we
have a foundation for respecting one
another. If the if we don't if we don't
uh acknowledge the authority of the
first table of the law, I have no reason
for respecting seventh day sabotarians.
Why should I why should I leave them
alone? Uh because I if I can't refer to
the fact that God is our authority, the
true and living God, not an idol, not
not Allah, not the God of the Hindus,
but the father of Abra, the the God of
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob, and the
father of Jesus Christ. If I acknowledge
him, then I should acknowledge
everything the Bible teaches about how
to respect people who differ with me on
as Paul says in in Romans 14 about a you
know, one one man considers every day
like another man considers this day. Uh
basically I want to refer to all of
scripture as we're deciding uh what to
do. So, no persecution of um
responsible, decent Christians who have
a different opinion about what day to
observe.
>> You might have trouble traveling on
Sunday because the gas stations are
closed. But Pastor Wilson, there's a
couple uh things there that I'd like to
address. You know, Thomas Jefferson uh
speaking on blasphemy said that it
neither picks my pocket nor breaks my
leg. If it be said his testimony in a
court of justice cannot be relied upon,
reject it. and he says, "It does me no
injury for my neighbor to say that there
are 20 gods or no god." Part of their
recognition was that the constitution as
the supreme law of the land would
protect in a case uh like if we had
somebody of a different religion in
power because ultimately the
constitution is based upon civil law.
And there's a distinction between civil
law and moral law. Moral law is
pertaining to God and civil law is
pertaining to fellow men. And you know
the concern that I have is once we start
trying to frame our nation in the
context of moral law, you cannot truly
enforce a moral government without an
inquisition. Because the law of God
actually pertains to the heart of an
individual and to actually ascertain the
heart of an individual, what they think
inside their mind to really pursue the
law to its full uh depth there would
require an inquisition. And that's
contrary to the new covenant in Hebrews
8 where it's the Holy Spirit that writes
the law on our hearts. It's not the
force of man. And you know I would say
it's the distinction between a
fundamental distinction that we have to
remember the difference between a sin
and a crime.
Okay. So the you're absolutely right
that when it comes to sins which is a
moral issue the government is absolutely
helpless and hopeless. I don't want lust
police. I don't want covetousness,
police. I don't want did you worship the
god mammon in your heart police. I don't
want I don't want the civil government
trying to reach into your inards at all.
It's none of their business. Uh they
they're not competent to do that.
>> But but but then you have a government
that is basically pursuing a man's not a
man's immorality but his inivility. It's
his univil behavior. We're based upon a
civil government. And my concern I want
I'm I'm talking about moral behavior,
moral and immoral behavior as opposed to
moral and immoral thoughts or opinions.
So, um, for example, I want our I want
our civil law, let's say, prohibiting
rape and murder. I that's a that's a
moral issue. Um, it's immoral to rape
and murder. And I want if someone says,
"Why shouldn't I be able to rape and
murder?" I want the civil magistrate to
say because God said to Moses on Mount
Si, you don't get to do that. So I want
a transcendent basis for the criminal
law. But I do absolutely believe in
liberty of conscience. So Thomas
Jefferson is right. If a man thinks and
says in his heart that I think there's
20 gods, yeah, knock yourself out. Think
that all think that all day. you what
you can't do is run for Congress and
legislate as though there were 20 gods.
That's what you that's what we that's
where I say no.
>> I I I think the Constitution adequately
responds to that by keeping separation
of church and state separate. Now, in
regards to murder, as you mentioned,
murder is an univil crime in our nation.
to actually pursue that under the
authority of of morality, you would also
have to be able to read a man's heart
because the Bible actually takes it so
far as if you are angry with the person
without a cause or or if you hate your
brother, that constitutes murder. Now,
one of the
>> civil law requires definitions.
Why is it we killed we killed 60 million
Americans? We killed them and we called
it a constitutional right. And I I want
to say so if I want to stand against
that, I want to stand against it with an
open Bible because if I if I appeal to
the constitution, they found the right
to privacy under which they hid all
these murders.
>> Correct? If you take this the secular
world they are actually legislating your
thoughts because uh if you take England
for example if you are thinking within
your heart in an area where there's an
abund clinic or praying within your mind
you can be arrested.
Now uh going to the opposite extreme is
not necessarily a solution for the
injustice that is being done by the
secular world.
And uh this is where where the issue
becomes a very gray issue.
And uh yes, we're we're just concerned
that if you start legislating morality
and legislating society and legislating
labor, eventually it will go in that
direction. Even even the 2025
uh document uh states that Sunday is the
default day. There is room for those
that keep the Sabbath. But if you want
an orderly society then there must be a
default eventually towards Sunday and
that is our basic concern. I'm very
happy to hear that you are saying that
there should be room for uh different
opinions on that issue but you are not
the sole voice out there and the voices
that we hear out there. Even Lenox said
uh it would be best in our interview
with him, it would be best if we
graduated and moved on towards the
Sunday because that would solve a big
problem.
>> Six days shalt thou labor and do all thy
work. Let's say I own a bakery and I'm
forced to close my business on Sunday.
Is that not impeding upon my free right
to keep the commandment and work six
days?
>> And again, this is I think where it gets
tricky. And I think for the sake of the
harmony of all of this, it would be much
easier if um my seventh day Adventist
friends just started to acknowledge
Sunday as the Lord's day. Then that way
we wouldn't run into those kinds of
issues. But I wouldn't say
>> you cannot
>> because of the deadline.
>> That would be the simplest um most
orderly way to do it because the vast
majority let's say we have a Christian
nation. The vast majority of Christians
in North America observe Sunday as the
Lord's day. Um, and if this were a
seventh day Adventist country or if you
postulate the formation of an Adventist
country somewhere and I and I went
there, I would fully expect uh to adjust
myself to that custom of of that people.
But in order to have in order to have
that happen, you have to have the
numbers basically. Uh so how how can an
orderly Christian society uh organize
itself on Christian principles while
doing its best to recognize and
accommodate the interests of the
minority. Now I I believe that the
American founding and the American uh
soft establishment of Christian faith uh
was the most successful in church
history to date in accomplishing this
task. I think we I think it had a good
run of 150 years or so 150 to 200 years
where it functioned and functioned well
and that's what I want to get back to. I
like the American settlement. I don't
like the harsh European settlements
where a denominational, you know,
there's a change. The king is now um a
congregationalist or the king is now uh
an Anglican and and you've everybody's
got to do it this way. I don't like
that. I I think that it's a bad idea. I
think that's what hap that what's that
is what contributes to the secularists
being able to revolt against the whole
idea and so consequently I am very much
in favor of the American approach to
firm convictions in our laws with
accommodation and accommodations and
carveouts for responsible citizens who
differ.
>> If I can kind of respond to a couple of
your points there. um you know you you
you kind of say well you have to have
the numbers basically um in the nation
to you know implement a law one way or
the other. Um but the problem is the
Jewish nation with Christ by and large
most of them rejected him. I mean even
his disciples fled. He was the only one
that was standing in the end. Um now
obviously you had Christendom that was
born and those disciples went forward
and evangelized others but as a whole
they said let his blood be on us and our
children. So the problem is is I mean
you you see examples of this where the
majority can be wrong and often is
wrong. Uh look at Hitler for example in
Germany you have um and I'm not equating
you know what you're you're doing
necessarily to Hitler. I'm just saying
like there's been cases in society where
the majority is wrong. Um and and
everybody recognizes that later. So the
you know part of the thing that we do
here at Heritage and Hope is we collect
old documents um and old books that talk
about the Protestant Reformation, that
type thing. I actually have a newspaper
here from 1888 that was talking about
the Blair Sunday rest bill that was
proposed because this was put forth by
Senator Hen Henry Blair and they wanted
a a universal day of rest on Sunday. And
this this newspaper here, the Christian
Union, they actually even though they
were Sunday keepers, they did not
recommend the bill actually. They said
that it it had too many issues. There
was too much trouble trying to enforce
it and it was going to basically trample
on a whole bunch of stuff. Now, a few
years after 1888, I had uh these posters
right here. Um these are from 1895.
And uh these posters uh basically are
news snippets from across the nation.
Mississippi, Nashville, Cincinnati,
uh going all across the country, St.
Louis, um Knoxville, a bunch of these
different places had Seventh Day
Adventists that were not abiding by the
blue laws of the time. So, for example,
you had a a guy who had his own property
and he was out digging a well on his own
property and he was doing it on Sunday.
Now, of course, the the blue law at the
time said, "You can't work on Sunday,
even on your own property." And so, he's
down there digging a well. Now, he's not
disturbing his neighbors. They can't
even see him. He's underground. He's not
making a bunch of noise. It's not like
he's out there like, you know, mowing
his lawn and keeping the neighbors up or
something like that. And so, they jailed
him. And actually, if you look at the
bottom of the page here, they put them
they put seventh day adventists in chain
gangs at the time. Um, and so the issue
is is I look at society and I look at
history because you know by looking at
history we can hopefully escape some of
the mistakes of the past. And by and
large when you have a combination of
church and state most of the time it
ends in persecution. you know, back in
um 1888 when this
>> when you have excuse me, when you have
people in power, most of the time it
ends in persecution.
It's ending in persecution now.
>> Well, you know, the the one thing with
the Sunday Rest bill in 1888 is we had a
couple members from our denomination
that went and and and basically fought
it, fought the Blair Act and said, "No,
like we shouldn't be doing this." And we
were asked at the time, okay, well,
let's assume that you guys were all in
power and it was a a large majority of
of Seventh Day Adventists, I'm assuming
you guys would want to put this law in
act. And we actually said no because the
issue is is again, if I'm enforcing
something that impedes your free right,
well, that's not the way of Christ. So
for example, let's say I'm a bakery shop
owner and
you know I I am forced to keep my shop
closed on Sunday. Is that not uh
impinging upon my free right to conduct
business six days of the week? Because
the commandment says six days shalt thou
labor? So in essence, even though it may
seem like, oh, it's not that big a deal,
um if you prevent me from working on one
day, is that not impeding my free right?
Yeah. So, you're talking to a big
advocate of let's be free with the
carveouts. I So, I don't have any
problem with the Adventist baker keeping
his shop open. But if he's in a town
with the majority of first day
observers, he might not get very good
business on that day because you I don't
want to force the Christian first day
observers to go shop uh at his bakery on
Sunday. But yeah, he can basically if he
is uh a responsible citizen and and not
a disturber of the peace and he wants to
dig his own well on Sunday or he wants
to have his shop open on Sunday, then do
it.
>> Well, pastor,
>> so so that's the um I believe that
religious toleration
is a fruit of a wellthought through
Christian nationalism. Well,
>> I I believe that toleration is part of
the package. I'm simply saying that the
the downstream consequences that you
guys are worried about, there are
downstream consequences to every system.
Everything the things that we're doing
now, there are downstream consequences.
Well,
>> Pastor Wilson, uh I'd like to provide
step back just for a moment and provide
a little bit of context here. So, we are
Protestants. We are Protestants of
Protestants. We join all the reformers
in identifying the pope as Antichrist.
Um you probably you may know the
difference between historicism, pritoism
and futurism. I just want to briefly uh
mention here we did see your your video
where you said that the popes even the
Renaissance ones even the worst of them
you said did not claim to be God.
>> Popes even the Renaissance popes even
the worst of them didn't claim to be
God. You know they were they would they
made grandiose claims for themselves but
they didn't go as far as Caligula.
>> Uh but we have right here actually the
Sakurosa Consilia. We've got uh another
Lucius Ferrer prompt biblote even canon
law right here where over and over and
over the popes actually use the same
Latin word from 2 Thessalonians 2 for
ostendens the pope ostendtor or showed
himself to be God. So this was actually
repeated over and over and over within
Catholicism. And so because we recognize
the pope as antichrist and joining all
of the reformers in that, we recognize
even further in revelation 14 that there
will be a crisis at the end of time over
the mark of the beast. And so we join
Thomas Tillum, we join uh John
Lavington, we join George Carlo, we join
Peter Chamberlain and many other
Protestants who recognize Sunday as the
mark of the beast in in the sense that
it is there will come a mark of the
beast test where Sunday will be enforced
by law. And it's interesting that even
within catechism 2176, Catholicism
recognizes Sunday as a sign. This is in
contrast to Exodus 31:17 where God
recognizes the 7th day Sabbath as his
sign. But you know when I recently I
believe it's one of your pastors uh back
in 2022 or at least somebody associated
uh Blaine Consati in June 16th 2022
wrote an article devotion Sabbath
observance as a mark of Christian
nations. And I found that usage of the
term very interesting in light of
Protestant history because if you go
through Protestant documents, there were
numerous Protestants who connected Mark
and sign specifically with the argument
over Saturday and Sunday. So as this law
gets established, we have long
anticipated 7th Day Adventists will be
the ones to tell the world that the mark
of the beast crisis has arrived. Those
who serve God will honor his sign. Those
who serve Rome and the God of this world
and antichrist, his changes to divine
times and laws in Daniel 7:25
will accept Sunday as their mark. So if
you had so honest question here, if you
had a a republic where the majority of
people were Seventh Day Adventists, why
would you tolerate um people in there uh
closing their shops on Sunday if it if
that's the mark of the beast? Why do you
why do you tolerate in your laws the
mark of the beast?
>> Because under our understanding of the
government of God, Christ said, "My
kingdom is not of this world. For if it
were, then would my servant fight. It is
the business of the gospel to convict
hearts, not to force hands. And when I
watched the interview with Steven Wolf,
he was okay with unregenerate forced
obedience.
>> Um I I just don't think you you're ever
going to escape the nature of politics,
which is agonistic. There's a struggle.
There's a point in which you you debate
and then if and then if you win, you win
and you essentially impose your will
upon those who disagree.
>> That is hypocrisy in the eyes of God.
And it is of no value in the new
covenant for and it and is consistent
with the mark of the beast in the hand
as opposed to in the mind because what
you have is obedience that is coerced,
but it's not actually in the heart of
man where a man's mind is changed, but
it's coerced in what the man does. Yeah,
I I agree. as a board me um as a board
member of a Christian school, we admit
um students who are not we we've had
students who were not from Christian
families and we don't uh we at the time
we didn't
long story but we have to just have kids
from believing families now because of
the legal climate but during the years
when we uh had non-Christian students
there uh we didn't compel them to
believe or confess anything inside in
their heart. We just said you have to
behave as though you were a Christian in
the hallways.
You you can't cuss, you can't blaspheme,
can't knock people over. You basically
these are Christian expectations,
Christian social expectations which we
expect you to conform to. Now, we don't
we didn't pretend that that regenerated
them or made them uh right with God.
We're it's just a a way of establishing
moral order. So, the things you you
can't enforce the issues of the heart.
You can't legislate regeneration. You
can't legislate love for God. You can't
and to try is impudent and silly and is
going to be counterproductive. Um, but
you can tell people that you are not
allowed to knock people down. You are
not allowed to uh engage in what's
called fighting words. So, a man may
entertain blasphemous thoughts or hold a
blasphemous doctrine. And I'd say leave
him alone. But if he walks up to someone
and engages in what you might call
fighting words, um, you know, he he's
blaspheming and railing and and
insulting, uh, that sort of thing. we
can uh tell them to put a sock in it.
You're disturbing the peace. You may not
blaspheme like that. Okay? U and so
consequently that's and all of that is
done
u with God's transcendent moral
authority and view. So when we enforce
criminal law external behavior only uh
we are doing it because we believe it's
a moral thing to do. But pastor Wilson,
even in the ancient Roman Empire,
Christianity was founded upon the
principle of blaspheming against other
people's gods in the context of getting
man getting people to disregard those
gods and to honor the true God by
speaking the truth about the God of
heaven. Well, they called it bl they
called it blasphe. The pagans called it
blasphemy but it wasn't because in Acts
uh in Acts where the riot in Ephesus
happened um the the city official was
able to say these men have not
blasphemed our goddess. They taught c
they they taught Christ and they started
the bad guys started the riot because
they they were accusing them of of this
but they didn't go around railing
against the false gods. Um e even the
archangel Michael fighting with de the
devil didn't rebuke didn't rail against
him either. So I believe we ought to
speak respectfully um of uh other
religions. Um so that's not a problem
either. Don't you think, Pastor Wilson,
that the church
uh especially in in the last few
centuries has done a pretty poor job of
selling the high moral values of
Christianity to the world. I mean, the
world has become so secularized.
I believe that one of the reasons why
that has happened is because the church,
especially many of the evangelicals,
claim that the law of God has been
nailed to the cross. Now the law of God
was never nailed to the cross. Not one
jot or one tit would disappear from the
law. It is the the the the shadow laws
that were nailed to the cross. Those
that were pointing to the coming of the
Messiah.
So when the church has done a very poor
job and the secular world has taken over
then it is it is a desire to to get the
state to help to reinstate some form of
morality. If you go back in history
Jesus never set up a kingdom where
Christianity ruled. He said the kingdom
of God has come near to you and people
are pressing in. And through the
centuries, whenever somebody tried to
set up a system where morality could be
dictated,
it ended up in persecution.
And why should we believe that? It all
bounds down to our view of the
millennium. And uh what is going to
happen in the millennium? I believe that
your view is that the church will
eventually conquer for Christ in this
world. But the biblical view according
to Daniel is that the God of heaven will
set up a kingdom in the time of these
last kings uh that come after the fall
of the Roman Empire into this the type
of world that we have now. that this
kingdom is one that God will set up and
not humanity on behalf of God.
>> So let's rewind for a minute because I
think there's a lot of area where we
agree. Um but let's just postulate a
Christian magistrate. All right. Um and
he's he confesses Christ. Now I agree
that he can't impose or bring about
anything with a top-down passing of
laws. The all of this has to begin with
reformation and revival in individual
lives in the church. People coming to
Christ. It's got to be established on
the bedrock of reformation and revival.
Okay? But let's say you've got a guy who
professes Christ. He's a magistrate. And
let's say he he starts to persecute a
seventh day uh you know he wants to put
an Adventist in a chain gang like the
like the example uh given before he's
doing that in the name of Jesus.
Jesus is at the right hand of God the
father right now and he's looking down
on this. Now my question is does Jesus
approve of what he's doing, disapprove
of what he's doing, or does he not care?
Right? Those are the three options.
Jesus approves of the persecution, he
disapproves of the persecution, or he
doesn't care. If Jesus doesn't care,
then we we shouldn't either. It doesn't
ma If Jesus doesn't care, then we don't
have to worry about it. If Jesus
approves of it, then we're all mistaken
here in this discussion. And if Jesus
disapproves of it, then that magistrate
ought to knock it off. He ought to
conform his behavior to what Jesus
wants. But as soon as he conforms his
behavior to what Jesus wants, I would
say, "Welcome to Christian nationalism."
>> Pastor Wilson, um, in watching your
interview with Answering Adventism, one
of the things that you mentioned was
that uh you could foresee uh ultimately
law where an Adventist could not buy a
shovel on a Sunday. I do believe that
the Sabbath is going to be part of a
reformation of our morals. I don't
believe the fourth commandment has been
uh retired in any way. So, if there is a
national reformation and revival, I
believe that that will result in a
national honoring of the Lord's Day. I
do believe that that's going to happen.
This is the extent of the persecution
that I'd be willing to um deploy against
a Seventh Day Adventist. He would not be
able to go into a shop and buy a shovel.
That's how that's the extent of the
pers.
>> Right. Right.
>> That would be the extent of the
persecution.
>> So my question would be I if you believe
that a law should restrict us from
buying a shovel on a Sunday, what would
happen? Uh what or what should be the
penalty be if we did go buy a shovel on
a Sunday? And if soft establishment
fails, I know you mentioned hard
establishment not being viewed as
unconstitutional in the early stages of
American history or or uh propose that.
So what should the penalty be if we do
not go along?
>> Okay. So um the the only reason the guy
would not be able to buy a shovel on
Sunday is the stores were all closed.
So, um, the the issue in my mind is if
if he had a neighbor who said, "Hey,
man, I'll sh I'll sell you my shovel and
that money changed hands, that sort of
thing." I think that for the Adventist
who bought a shovel on Sunday, there
should be zero penalty. Zero.
>> But would the businesses be closed by
law?
>> Um, yeah. I'd say primarily by custom,
but mostly by law.
>> Excuse me. mostly by custom, but you I
could expect um uh legal reinforcements
of it or or whatever.
>> I have no problem with I have no problem
with uh the stores being closed on
Sunday because if I needed a shovel, I
could couldn't buy it on a Wednesday and
I'm sure I would get by without having
to buy it on a Sunday. My issue is what
if I am forced not to keep my Sabbath
and to to work on that particular day or
uh face penalties. Those kinds of laws
were almost introduced into Greece quite
recently where they almost legislated a
six- day work week in order to
get the economy going again because they
were in a in a dire straits
and then there was again only one
synchronized day left and this is the
issue and coming back to does Jesus care
did he care during the inquisition when
thousands tortured and and burnt at the
stakes. Yes, of course he cared. But uh
>> so they should have stopped it.
>> They should have. Yes, they should have
>> in the name of Jesus. All I'm saying is
they should have stopped it because it
was God's will that they stop it.
>> If I can also just ask something. I
think you've mentioned quite a few
things that um I think we agree on
definitely even if there's a choice if
for somebody to have open his shop on a
Sunday and if Sabbath keeper want to
keep it closed on a on a Saturday uh
that will be fine. I don't think we have
a problem with that. I think where um
James earlier mentioned a little bit is
because we look at what prophecy is
saying and where we are heading and we
see that all these tentacles are in
current currently in government and also
on the Supreme Court. the majority being
Roman Catholic and that bringing in all
the things is set up correctly that when
the Christian nationalism starts maybe
being implemented who will be the
driving force will it be a view like you
have or will it be coming from the Roman
Catholic side
>> yes the the
>> there are people exc I'll just put it
this way I think that there are people
alive and ar arguing for things who if
they came out on top of the Christian
nationalist movement and they were
calling the shots uh they would be
saying things and doing things that you
guys wouldn't like at all. I think that
if I were in the position where I was
rep you know people and uh like me were
representing Christian nationalism I
think you would have nothing to worry
about at all. you you would get all the
waiverss and all the carveouts. Um that
um I'm I want to be super accommodating
on things like that. Um but I I think
that we have to decide to do something.
So um I remember when I was in the Navy
in the 1970s, I was stationed in
Virginia and I remember there's a
referendum in Virginia in the 70s uh
getting rid of the last of the blue
laws, right? You know that it was not
this is not ancient history. The these
are live these are live issues and blue
laws could very easily come back and
when they come back I think we ought to
have uh respect for liberty of
conscience baked into them. Um and
that's part that's but that's part of
the American settlement and had we've
had we figured this out centuries ago
and I think we've got a good system. I
think we had a good system.
>> I appreciate that you stand for these
principles but as we have stated others
might be not so tolerant when it comes
to these issues in the future.
>> And that is why even even implementing
something like this eventually has the
builtin danger of escalating to the
points that we are talking about.
>> Right. But I think it's less dangerous
than where we are now. If I can also say
I don't know if you are very familiar
with South African history and the
recent history like went through the
apartate era and all of that and during
the apartate era we we had very
stringent Sabbath uh um blue laws that
was implemented and that was a recent
history in our country and the the
persecution that came from that was
quite harsh
and
for me And I'll just give you a little
bit background. I used to be uh I wasn't
always a seventh adventist and none of
us actually but um the convincing took
over but growing up in that time we were
100% agreed because we had a Christian
government
>> Christian nationalist
>> a Christian nationalist government it
was reform and look so we are very weary
because we have recently come out of it
and we saw what it did in a in recent so
you understand why it's such a the seven
adventists have a very and we link it to
prophecy because prophecy says it will
be repeated so that's the
>> so when that stopped we actually went to
the opposite extreme of secularism and
anything goes and that of course is not
acceptable either so the tendency of
human nature is to let the pendulum
spring from one extreme to the other
>> aren't Martin Luther said that humans
were like the drunk who falls off his
mule on the left side and then the next
time falls off the right side to keep it
even.
>> Correct. And and that is that is our
view. And as we said because we link it
to prophecy
that that becomes an issue.
>> Pastor Wilson, one of the remarks uh we
were going to ask is where you find
Sunday in scripture. And I of course I
know that that's uh we can we can
discuss the usual text of Acts 20:7 and
uh uh 1 Corinthians 16, but one thing
that we responded to Lennox on because
we did see your response on 1
Corinthians 16.
>> Well, the first thing to note is that
Paul was authoritative authoritatively
requiring them to do it in a particular
way. He says on the first day of the
week, everyone was to set aside a
particular amount as God had blessed
him. Now, this had to have been a
collection at church. It had to have
been a collection at church because the
reason he says, "I want you to do it
this way is so that there be no
gatherings when I come." All right. The
thing to to note about this passage is
how Paul describes Sunday. How he
describes Sunday. Your translation
probably says first day of the week, but
that's not what it is in the Greek. The
phrase me on sabatu first day of the
week is first a first day Sabbath. It's
the first day of the it's the first day
of the week is being called a Sabbath.
The first day of the week is being
called a Sabbath.
>> And weren't sure if you were aware in
1899 the Methodist Review actually wrote
an article warning their people that the
argument about first day Sabbath and 1
Corinthians 16 was they called it fool's
gold. They said, "Must syntax die that
the Sabbath may live." Uh stating to
their people, "Tell it not in Gath.
Publish it not in the streets of Battle
Creek," of which is very famous as far
as Adventists uh kind of a center of
Adventists, lest the daughters of the
Sabotarians rejoice, lest the daughters
of the Sat Sadarians triumph. And their
argument was going through the LXX,
going through the Mckelta,
uh, and numerous other sources
demonstrating that there really isn't a
support for 1 Corinthians 16:2 as first
day Sabbath. In fact, if you go into the
Mckela, for example, you should remember
it from Sunday so that if you if
something and Sabaton actually first
first day Sabaton, uh, so that something
nice comes to hand, you should set it
aside for the sake of the Sabbath. So
even within Judaism, it was common in
celebration of the Sabbath to actually
set aside something on the first day of
the week. But uh of course we could go
through some of the other texts like
Luke 18:12 fasting twice on the week
Sabaton uh tithe as many things as I
gain of course being two days of the
week or for example the LXX where there
were psalms for first day of the week,
second day of the week, the day before
the Sabbath and so on using Sabaton in
the weekly sense. So um really in the
context the argument in 1 Corinthians 16
as stating first day Sabbath, the Sunday
keepers themselves warned their people
not to use it against 7th day Sabbathke
keepers because the overwhelming
evidence points to the other direction
uh apart from 1 Corinthians 16:2. Do you
have any other text that clearly
supports Sunday?
>> The two the two passages I would mention
and obviously you can write a book on on
this. So, I'm just going to touch on
them so you know where uh I'm coming
from. Uh in Hebrews where it says there
remains therefore a sabotasmos for the
people of God. I think it's 49 and yeah.
>> Um in in 10 it says uh for uh he ceased
from his labor as God ceased from his
labor in the creation.
All right. And I used to puzzle over
that because that's an odd comparison
because I used to take it as a works
righteousness guy trying to save himself
by good works and then he ceases from
his labor. But what why compare that to
God creating the world and ceasing from
his labor? I now take it as referring to
Christ and his um his death b and
burial. And so Christ ceased from his
labor
um in the same way that God ceased from
his labor. So when God created the
world, he then entered his rest on the
seventh day. Uh Christ ceased from his
labor, death, burial, and entered into
his rest on the first day. Uh so that so
Hebrews um that that passage in Hebrews
is one of the first places I would look.
And the other place that I think is
really interesting that I I want to do a
lot more uh work on is every
resurrection appearance of the Lord. Uh
you know when the women go out to the
tomb
it says they go out on the and if you
look at the Greek in all of these
passages they go out on the first day
Sabbath.
Okay the right it's not the first day of
the week but they go out on the first
day Sabbath. So the word Sabbath is
expressly used in every resurrection
appearance where Christ rose again from
the dead on the first day Sabbath. So
there's a seventh day Sabbath and
there's a first day Sabbath. So those
those would be the places that I would
um want to talk about first.
>> The Jews didn't have the days of the
week like we have them today which are
basically pagan names. They reckoned the
the days of the week in reference to the
Sabbath. So they would say the Sabbath
and then first day after the Sabbath or
first day Sabbath, second day, third day
Sabbath. So they would reckon it after
the Sabbath until they get to the
Sabbath again.
>> That's where that terminology comes from
>> with week.
>> Yeah. Actually, if you look at 1
Corinthians 16:2 and you actually pull
up the interlinear version of it there,
that word sabado, uh it you you look at
the references and there's several
references where it's talking about the
specific day, but then there's also
several references where it's talking
about it as a week. And so you you see
this distinction where it's actually
used for two different things. And so,
can you only use it one way and say,
"Well, that's the way." Well, you have
to look at the greater context, which is
why it's in my opinion a little bit of a
weak argument there because you have it
used as the word week. Sabado as a week
as as a reference to the week uh rather
than just the specific day. Yes. So Luke
18:12 is an example of this. But also if
you go to the LXX, one of the things
that just going from Hebrew into Greek,
you're looking at and then of course the
the Jewish scholars recognized even in
the Hebrew word Sabbath for Leviticus
23:15, it's translated into abdomas for
week in the alx there. So they
recognized that under certain contexts
that Sabbath was a reference to week.
And this goes back to our previous
argument on 1 Corinthians 16:2 for first
day or first day Sabbath or or whatever.
Uh you know, not only did the Mckela
recognize and use the same words uh to
reference first day Sabbath talking
about setting something aside, which the
Jews would do in preparation for the
seventh day of the week. But again the
if you go to the Psalms in the LXX and
even in Jerome's Vulgate actually they
have uh Sabaton actually referenced for
first day of the week, second day of the
week, third day of the week, etc. There
was a psalm for every different day of
the week. So unless you're going to
call, you know, Wednesday a Sabbath and
and everything else in in in all the
holy reverence, it doesn't make it
doesn't make any sense. Then it falls
apart. It's all pointing to the seventh
day Sabbath. So, I'm going to have to
let you guys have the last word because
I need to go.
>> All right. Well, we greatly enjoyed you
coming on. I thank you so much for
sitting down and and conversing with us
and uh uh thank you so much.
>> Thank you. I appreciated the cordial
conversation.
>> Wonderful to meet you. Thank you very
much.
>> All right. Bye-bye.
All right. So, uh uh Pastor Wilson had
to had to leave. Um but we appreciate
him coming and and speaking with us, but
you know, just kind of your final
thoughts to kind of wrap up what we uh
what we were talking about so we don't
end quite so abruptly. Um James, kind of
talk me through a little bit more about
what you were saying in regards to 1
Corinthians 16. Uh and uh uh Walter
Martin, I would love to know your
thoughts as well on this.
>> Yeah. So, first off, he's talking about
Sabaton as though it's first day
Sabbath, as though this text establishes
that now Sunday is the Sabbath. Now,
first off, within Catholicism, they
themselves recognize that there's a
distinct difference between the Sabbath
and Sunday, which they say
chronologically follows the Sabbath each
week, even in the catechism. But
nevertheless, the there was an article
in the Methodist Review in 1899 warning
their people not to use this, calling
this argument fool's gold because the
combined testimony, the LXX, the
Septuagent, and the Talmud, actually
refutes this position entirely because
if you look from a Jewish perspective,
and again, he's appealing to that
history there. Not only did the Jews
themselves use first day Sabbath or
first day or first Sabaton as a
reference to the seventh day Sabbath
themselves but also they themselves in
with Paul uh actually set aside
something on the first day Sabbath or
first day of the week really how it's
translated in preparation for the
Sabbath but also he's not addressing the
broader context that there was a famine
going on at this time and so collections
were being made in reference to the
famine. And so, uh, there's really not
sufficient evidence here in this text
for establishing that this was going to
be a practice to continue. And it was a
practice sufficient to change the law of
God. Um, and he overlooked Luke 18:12.
I fast twice in the week. Sabaton being
translated very clearly as week there.
And of course, we know that the fast
took place two days out of the week. And
so the the the textual Greek evidence
actually doesn't back him up.
>> And it's not only one or two. All of the
major Protestant denominations
have official documents even sometimes
within their creeds that there is not
one text in the Bible that uh mandates
the first day of the week as the
Sabbath. They all agree that biblically
the seventh day is the Sabbath, the
Saturday. And right from the beginning
when Protestantism separated
from Catholicism, the Archbishop of Reio
used that very principle to determine
that Protestants were were not a a a
sister but a daughter that had become
rebellious because they they didn't
adhere to solar scriptura according to
their own dictates but listened or
obeyed a law of Catholic and only
Catholic origin which happened to be the
Saturday.
>> The other thing that he overlooked was
in referencing Hebrews 4:10 as resting.
He he conceds that at the creation of
the world, God rested on the seventh day
and he conceds that Christ rested in the
tomb. Then later on asserts that somehow
Christ rested on the first day of the
week. But if you're resting as God
rested,
it's actually qualified in verse four of
the same chapter as the seventh day.
>> Mhm.
>> So the same chapter is referencing
creation there. And to rest as God
rested in the comparative sense, if
you're strict to the text, verse four
clinches it as the seventh day.
>> Yeah. You can't change it. You can't
move it then on to the first day. And
this is just it was interesting to me.
If you look at all of this, there are
quite a few different angles that people
um take on against the Saturday Sabbath.
Some agree that it is still the Sabbath,
but from what I could gather, this is
not I would have loved to ask him still,
but from what I've gathered that from
Lenox, they don't believe it. They
believe that the Lord's day now is
Sunday uh Sunday and that's the Sabbath
now. It's not Saturday anymore. Then you
get people that acknowledge the sab
sabbath but you don't have to keep it
because you can keep any day of the week
according to
>> right
>> the scripture says the disciples rested
according to the commandment and on the
first day of the week they went to uh to
bring the spices to the tomb and as you
correctly said he stated that Christ
rested basically went into his rest on
the first day everything but uh his
intercession
as as the lamb of God, as the high
priest uh is what commenced on the first
day of the week. That is when his
inauguration took place. That's why he
said to to Mary at the tomb, do not
detain me or do not hold me back because
I have not yet ascended to the father.
And there the inauguration took place
which was symbolized by the the
splashing of the blood onto the robe of
the priest and then he returned. So in
actual fact rather than resting he
commenced his work as the lamb of God,
the high priest, the intercessor, the
advocate for the ch people of God to
this very day.
So rather than rest which he did in the
tomb, uh he actually started his his
heavenly ministry and atonement in in
heaven.
>> You know, one thing I was going to point
out to him uh if I had the chance was to
to show him this this catechism um that
says very clearly in here uh that
there's no scriptural background or
there's no scriptural backup for the
change of the day. And so if you're
truly solos scriptorra, you would keep
the Sabbath, the seventh day Sabbath
holy.
>> Yeah. Even John Ek who was uh Luther's
opponent said regards to Sunday, nolum
habastorum, we don't have scripture.
>> And um it is interesting if we could
further this. You remember in our
discussion with Lenox when I asked him
so when the scripture in revelation says
that from one Sabbath to another we'll
get together in heaven will that then be
Sunday according you know and I I
believe that even pastor Doug Wilson
will will agree with that now if that is
true then that means that becomes they
see the fourth commandment is Sunday
and then
>> then there's the change of the
commandments
>> is a change of the commandments
>> and not one jot or one turtle change
>> and they want the commandments to be
uh instituted through laws. So even I I
agree I can see that he does not agree
with persecution
but inevitably if you want to legislate
the fourth commandment and you believe
that the Sabbath that's preenov in there
is Sunday
inevitably that will be enforced.
>> If if you legislate any of the four
commandments on the first table it will
lead to persecution. There is no other
option. It will start off maybe good but
history has shown us
it is not going to end well.
>> Yeah. He spoke frequently of carving out
uh exemptions but the elephant in the
room that I don't think he's addressing
is you know if Adventists are going out
there preaching that Sunday legislation
when that law comes you know we're we're
here for the mark of the beast test.
Wouldn't that be viewed as blasphemy?
Wouldn't that be viewed ultimately as
preaching against the God that they
serve?
>> It's anti-establishment.
>> Uh and therefore, what is to prevent
more and more laws to deal with that
loud cry and to escalate the
persecution? And he he references how
hard establishment was not viewed as
unconstitutional in the early stages of
American history. If if that was not
unconstitutional, then what barrier is
there to prevent the nation going to
hard establishment when that time comes?
>> When I can't remember, I think James you
or Alex you asked him
uh how does it work then must the Sunday
blue laws be legislated? And then he
said yes. But if it's legislated, where
will the Adventist have the choice not
to to keep his shop open then? Well,
that's the thing.
>> Sunday also said
>> how how are you going to do that?
Because basically, if you put it so that
anybody can put in an exemption. Okay.
Number one, your exemption will have to
be approved by the state. Otherwise,
anybody could put in an exemption as and
and then there's no point of the law
because it's not going to do anything.
>> Okay?
>> If if he's thinking of business more
than his religion, he'll be wanting to
keep his shop open. In any case,
>> one thing that has uh been proved by
history is that it tends to repeat
itself, right?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> If you go back, I think it was the 11th
century when there was the Senate of
Tus.
And in that Senate, they were
legislating against those that kept the
Saturday Sabbath, which in itself is an
argument that the seventh day Sabbath
was kept even in that century.
And if it was the 11th or the 10th, I'm
not quite sure now. But any case, that
senate determined that the first step
would be the forfeiture of all your
substance if you didn't align yourself
with the Sabbath with the Sunday Sabbath
and the next step after that would be
harsher penalties of imprisonment and
the final step would be death. So there
is a progression and history has a
tendency to repeat itself.
Maybe we can also let just make clear to
viewers and maybe people that are not
Adventists and are watching this that we
do not advocate for everything that's
going on in the world at this stage. We
agree with the people that it's in a
total chaotic state.
>> Of course,
>> so we're not there here saying no, we
don't want anything to be moral that
route. But if they have a problem to
understand why we say these things,
maybe it's interesting go and have some
look at some of the explanations on what
we called prophecy. What prophecy is
stating what will take place.
>> Yes. What is interesting to me very
interesting to me that the first stage
in the implementation of the mark of the
beast is buying and selling. In other
words, it's an economic measure to force
you in a particular direction. If we
look at what's happening in the United
States of America right now, and there
is no official church and state
together, there is just uh a tendency in
that direction already. They are using
economic measures,
for example, against universities and
against wokeness and against various
organizations that that do not uh comply
with these these issues. The withdrawing
of vast amounts of money from
universities and forcing them through
economic measures. Eventually if they
don't work and the situation becomes
worse then will they take a next step
imprisonment
and if that doesn't work will they take
a next step and this is this is the the
way in which history has gone and you
cannot legislate the kingdom of God. God
himself says the scripture will set up a
kingdom and the entire structure of the
secular government will be swept away.
It will become powder. It will be dust.
It will be removed and the God of heaven
will set up a kingdom that will never be
removed. and this is going to end
catastrophically
even though he has uh a mind to be
accommodating.
Uh the rest of the team is not going to
play that ball.
>> Well, when I was when I was discussing
uh persecution and how people were in
chain gangs and that type thing and I
said, you know, we worry about this
happening again type thing, he said,
well, wouldn't that be better than
what's going on currently? Yeah, that's
that's exactly what we said. We
>> do two wrongs make a right? No. No.
>> The other thing here to consider is even
now on Twitter X, there are some
Christian nationalists who are already
discussing the death penalty.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. You can see posts on there where
they talk about would you use your
second amendment rights for blue laws.
It's like second amendment has to do
with weapons. Why would you be using
weapons in regards to a day of rest? Uh,
and so there's there's people, now I'm
not saying these are, you know, famous
people or politicians or anything, but
there's people out there who are
discussing this. Um, and so when you
have uh someone who's pushing this
forward, I mean, it's going to happen.
>> It's going to the kingdom of God is
within. God is gathering his people into
his kingdom. by using his word to direct
them into the principles of heaven. It's
a personal choice that you make. And
that kingdom has been pressing in ever
since Christ came to this world and will
continue to do so. And in the
resurrection and the final translation,
those that have made a personal choice,
not by legislation,
but by conviction through the Holy
Spirit, they will comprise the kingdom
of God and no one else. In 1785,
Memorial and Remonstrance against
religious assessments, James Madison on
religious liberty wrote that it is
proper to take alarm at the first
experiment on our liberties. who does
not see the same authority which can
establish Christianity in exclusion of
all other religions may establish with
the same ease any particular sect of
Christians in exclusion of all other
sects that the same authority which can
force a citizen to contribute 3 pence
only of his property for the support of
any one establishment may force him to
conform to any other establishment in
all cases whatsoever.
It it's very interesting referencing the
early founders of America. They were not
in favor even with uniting the Christian
religion with the state power because
invariably you have mankind trying to
establish a particular
uh flavor of Christianity that as
history reveals is uh very consistent
every time with a false version.
>> Blood always flows when there are
legislation on religion
and prophecy is on our side. we can see
it developing or it's very
you know I I also mentioned that we
would have loved to ask on Babylon is
fallen is fallen but even the many many
twice it was church and state that was
fallen the same in revelation now they
want to put it back the Bible says when
it comes back there will be persecution
>> you know when when there was the great
revival in the time of the time period
of 1844.
Uh the great revivalists in the United
States were millennialists. They were
preaching that the kingdom of God was at
hand and that they were going to set up
the kingdom. And in the midst of this
chaos, God raised up William Miller and
he came with a message which was
contrary to that, namely
premillennialism.
uh that Christ would come himself and
set up the kingdom and not man do it for
him because that has never succeeded
throughout history and I don't believe
it will succeed now either but that the
God of heaven would set it up and it is
it is a fact of history that only a
minority accepted the Millerite view. It
is spreading in Adventism
and it's basically the only group that
is left that is preaching
premillennialism. But it is so
profoundly biblical. Every single
principle that Christ preached about his
coming is about him setting up the
kingdom. the prophecies in Daniel, the
prophecies in uh the book of Revelation,
the 10 toes in the time of these kings,
he will set up his kingdom, the horns
and the kings, the 10 kings in in
Revelation, they will give their power
unto the beast and they will be contrary
to Christ. It it is a repeat of history.
And I I don't know whether we as a
denomination have done a good enough job
to preach premillennialism to the world
because it seems to me that the entire
evangelical world is on the other
bandwagon just as it was in the time of
the Millerites.
>> Absolutely. You know, one one thing that
I was planning on kind of pointing out
to him is when you look at the three
angels message in Revelation,
uh you know, there's there's the warning
and then it it says uh and the smoke of
their torment ascendeth up forever and
ever and they have no rest day or night.
So there's this concept of the wicked
not having rest. But then if you go to
Matthew uh 11 28-30, it says, "Come unto
me all ye that labor and are heavy
laden. I will give you rest. Take my
yoke upon you and learn of me for I am
meek and lowly in heart and ye shall
find rest unto your souls." So there's
this concept of the wicked not having
rest
and the righteous having rest.
And so it's interesting that in the
three angels message when it talks
about, you know, just a few verses
before it's talking about this mark
or, you know, in his forehead or in his
hand. If you get that mark, you're not
resting. You don't have spiritual rest.
Um, and I I I think that that's not done
by accident that God talks about the
wicked not having that spiritual rest.
uh we are told that the third angel's
message is righteousness by faith in
verity. In other words, the only rest
that we can ever find in terms of our
salvation is resting in the completed
work of Jesus Christ. And uh to say that
the sa that Sabbathkeeping is works
based is a oxymoron
because how can rest be works at the
same time. So when you enter into his
rest, you enter into his completed work
and that is symbolized by the completion
of of creation which has a memorial
which is the Sabbath. It's fascinating
to me that Christ in his triumphant
entry entered into Jerusalem on the
first day of the week and that entire
week is documented.
And then when it comes to the Friday
which is the preparation day, it goes
into the hours. Whereas the other days
are referenced as days. The the
preparation day is referenced in hours.
It was this hour and this hour and it
was the 9th hour when Christ died which
was 3:00 in the afternoon. making it
very clear that that the Sabbath was
approaching and that there was a short
period of time for him to be placed in
the tomb and the Sabbath came. So it is
actually the antithesis or it is the the
fulfillment of the creation week in the
recreation week. One of the first things
he did in the triumphant entry was the
second cleansing of the temple
and then his teachings and then becoming
the lamb of God. And that act was as
much a a creation because the recreation
is actually even greater than the
creation.
So it is a mirror of what happened in
the creation week. And to tear it apart
and remove the typology by changing the
days makes no sense whatsoever. The
triumphant entry where for the first
time he was acknowledged as the king
because they worshiped him as the king
and the messiah as he entered. That was
a exact copy of the creation week. And
therefore, the Sabbath stands in that
week because they rested according to
the commandment.
>> You know, I've got a clip here. I'm
going to play just real fast from Doug
just to kind of demonstrate a little bit
of what he actually believes about some
of the Protestant positions, for
example, on Antichrist. Let's take a
look right here.
>> Nero persecuted the church from AD64 to
AD68. But your view demands that this
book be written before 8070 which is a
very difficult case to make in view of
the external evidence.
>> It's easier than you think. But the
point is this
>> if you want to believe that it's easy
>> but we don't have time for it now. The
the point the point is that Nero who
occupied the the right place on the
number of heads of the beast persecuted
the saints of God for 42 months. One of
the concerns that I think of course we
have is in identifying Nero there as the
one spoken of in for the 42 months of
revelation and 1260 days of Daniel is
that he's ultimately taking the
prophetic positions of Alkazar in his
vetsio arani sensus and apocalypsy which
specifically identified Nero as that
individual for the 42 months. So this is
this is prophetic positions ultimately
direct from the Jesuits and the
counterreformation that is actually
absolutely where these positions are
built upon it's directly built upon Rome
>> most of these sideline stuff like uh
post breerism
futurism is all it's all the same comes
from the Jesuits
>> it's all Jesuit doctrine in fact the
entire entire
uh apocalyptic
beliefs structure of the evangelical
world is based on Jesuit teaching and
not on the Bible.
>> Yep. Well, you know, I think uh I think
it's important that we remember that
when you grow up and you are taught
Sunday rest from your youth and that's
all you know growing up. It's ingrained
in you and you get into this belief
structure. It's very difficult to
change. I think it really takes the Holy
Spirit to to to help change your mind so
that you can see the truth. And so, um,
we shouldn't be
hostile or or, uh, pjorative or anything
to someone who has these beliefs.
Instead, we should pray for them
>> and say, you know, there's there's
confusion out there and clearly we
disagree with Douglas Wilson, but it's
not that we hate him or that we that we
uh uh, you know, think evily of him or
anything like that. Instead, we we want
him to see the truth as it is in Jesus
and to see uh the the truth so that he
can be warned about what is coming on
this world. And I hope I hope that our
discussion here about Sunday laws and
what's coming when he starts seeing it
happen and he starts seeing the
persecution, I hope that he chooses the
right side. Um because uh I don't want
the devil to claim not even one more
human for his side in this great
controversy battle that's going back and
forth. Um, and so I I I want to make
sure that we're not um seeming like this
is just an attack. It's not. Actually,
I'm I was grateful to have a a deep
conversation with him um where we could
have a peaceful deep conversation and I
appreciated that he was very polite and
he gave us a full hour of of his time to
discuss with us. Um and so I'm grateful
that he was able to talk with us.
>> Yeah. If I may just quickly say
something um that links on to our
discussion that we had with Lenox and
maybe we can just make it clear here for
the people out there that's viewing it
because there was quite some hostility
in some of the comments that was made on
that video with Lenox condemning
condemning him and all of those things.
I think we must get a spirit of prayer
and compassion for and
>> even Steven when he was stoned didn't
retaliate
>> right
>> so that is the type of spirit we have to
take these type of discussions with
>> and the and the other issue is we are
not doubting the sincerity of any of of
these people I believe they are sincere
they see the the state of the world and
everybody is appalled at the state of
the world and what can we do to correct
it. And the problem as we address it is
that the state
legislating morality eventually leads to
the wrong things. And if we can bring
this thought across to them, I believe
that many when they see the events
taking place, and I really mean many,
will realize it's going in the wrong
direction. We have to stick to the word
of God. The kingdom of God is something
that happens within and cannot be
enforced from without. And it is that
final decision which will determine who
is part of the kingdom of God and who is
not.
>> Uh I I fully agree.
>> One of the uh things that you know I
think it's important for pastor Wilson
to be aware of is it was our people that
actually filed an amicus brief with
Grath versus DeJoy in defense of the
religious liberty of those who we
disagree with. So, we are supportive of
religious liberty. And you know, one
comment that I saw from the Linux video
actually as a follow-up as to these
discussions and the influence that
they're having upon others was one that
I I really enjoyed. A pastor from the
Church of Christ in North Carolina. He
stated that even I can easily see there
is no biblical authority to change the
Sabbath, a day sanctified and made holy
by God. Sunday is absolutely not the
Lord's day. There is a big difference
between the Ten Commandments and the
Mosaic law. May God bless all the men in
this discussion. I'm I'm very happy that
as a result uh people's lives are being
changed and and seeing the truth and we
pray that more see it as time goes on.
>> And I think that was our original
purpose here is not necessarily that we
believe we can convince Douglas Wilson
of the difference. I mean the Holy
Spirit is the one who does the
convicting but rather the point of this
whole discussion is actually to showcase
why they believe this way, how they
believe this way. And you know, we need
to be able to have an answer for
everyone that asks us what we believe.
So, uh, you know, Walter, you said that
there's many different ways that they go
about trying to have support for Sunday.
Some will say, "Oh, it's changed in
scripture." Others will say, "Oh, the
law has been done away with," or, "Well,
the law is relevant, but we don't have
to keep it anymore." And so, for each of
those specific points, as Seventh Day
Adventists, if we're facing this crisis,
we have to be able to give an answer for
each of those. If you are interacting
with somebody in your daily life and
they come up to you and they they start
discussing it and they suddenly seem to
have more interest or knowledge in it
than you previously maybe took them for.
Maybe it's a co-orker, maybe it's a
friend. Can you actually explain your
position? And so that's the purpose of
this kind of video and this kind of
discussion. It's not a gotcha type thing
or anything like that. Instead, we're
simply trying to show the logic behind
it and and where we can stand on
scripture as our firm guide.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. That's the one side and there's
one more side.
Uh the issue is in your own heart. How
do you how do you understand this? And
where are we heading? We have for years
been preaching that the events taking
place before our eyes will take place.
We have been preaching that the mark of
the beast will be implemented. We have
been preaching that there will be
economic measure taken against those who
do not keep it. That there will be a
death decree eventually. And when people
actually see these things taking place
before their eyes that they may be aware
of it and make a decision. So this is
not necessarily to condemn someone but
tell but to inform them where we are
standing in the stream of time because
uh Wilson himself said that he puts off
the coming of Christ for over 200 and
something years 260 I don't know exactly
what the number was that he mentioned at
least
and uh I don't see it like that when you
see these things happening then lift up
your heads in other words Ask God to
impress you as to what is right and what
is wrong and make a decision based on
scripture and not on on the basis of
coercion.
>> Amen. Amen. Well guys, uh thank you so
much for joining us here at Heritage and
Hope. Uh we hope you enjoyed this very
special episode. Don't forget to like,
share, and subscribe to this YouTube
channel and uh head on over to Clash of
Minds as well as there's lots of videos
upcoming here soon. Thank you for
joining us.